hi i'm tamwyn and i'm an atheist hi i'm
jonathan and i'm a christian
and we've been together for 13 years
i think i am an atheist because i feel
like the world already has enough
problem as it is
and i feel like religion is one of those
problems i know that sounds
something that you don't no i can
actually understand that because
religion is politics you know that's a
really big
you know thing that happens in our world
every single day i mean the reason why
we fight is a lot of times because of
the things that we believe so i can
understand you know where you're coming
from as far as
you know why you chose to be atheist but
doesn't it kind of
suck like you don't never feel empty
like when you're an atheist
like i mean you just you just believe in
nothing like when you die like you know
this this is going to be eternal
darkness
like there's no afterlife i think you
think that i believe in like
absolutely nothing which is not true i
believe that faith i believe in hope
and you can have hope and faith without
having like
god in your life i feel like people that
are christian they use it as an excuse
to say like oh i'm i'm this but i'm a
christian so it's okay
and i feel like if i'm an atheist then i
could just be free and
not like be so you know judgmental
well um i'm a christian because i feel
like many christians it's been instilled
from us or
in us from birth and a lot of times like
our parents like really don't give us an
option
to be something else but honestly since
i've grown up with it and like you know
and it's and it's always been in me like
i just
i feel it and the big thing that
happened to me when i was a child was
every night before me and all my
my siblings went to sleep my mother came
in our bedroom and then
took some anointing oil and you know
that was our foreheads with it
and did uh you know the crucifix and
like you know it's just like a you know
it was like a
you know a protective like kind of like
covering you know that type of thing you
know as we slept and um
that's just you know these are some of
the things that like has stuck with me
throughout my childhood for her to
believe in it so much
and for her to grow me into believing it
as well
like it just meant that like just this
this is a very strong power this is a
very strong you know entity but stuff
like that scares me though actually
like the cross and all that i don't even
know how to do it it's just surprising
holy cow and you put a little kiss in
there too you know what i'm saying it's
something i like to do with kids
[Music]
the first couple months was really hard
for sure i mean the first couple years
like the first two years we didn't have
cell phones we didn't have a car we
didn't have jobs
so we were like 14 15
and we made it work we saw each other
once a month
we would write letters to each other he
would hand write me letters and i still
have all of them actually
um in a box with all the flowers that he
gave me that are dead because i
used to collect them but starting to
kick up a good smell
in the apartment i actually like the
smell oh my god you see that
i think it smells beautiful it smells
prettier like it smells better than like
new roses i remember on one of the dates
your mom
asked me what i believed in she did not
she did i wanted to
say that i was christian just so i could
get her approval well i just want to say
i apologize for that i didn't know that
i mean
it's the first time i'm hearing this
after 13 years i mean i mean i kind of
feel bad i mean i didn't you know you
don't have to apologize i don't really
talk about it because i don't want
anything to be casted upon you you know
i understand that
[Music]
i didn't really think about it i mean
especially not when i met you
religion never really came to my mind
like growing up like oh okay like he has
to be
you know buddhist blah blah because my
family my parents are buddhists like
my siblings i have there's eight of us
and we're all different from each other
which is crazy
but i never that was not something that
i thought about growing up
i think religion started like affecting
our relationship when we
started becoming young adults i think
that's when
your parents started asking me to go to
church with you
back to when we wanted to move in
together your mom would ask me to go to
church
and i would feel totally uncomfortable
but i would still go because i love you
his family they're all like pastors
they're all like super religious
and i would go to church with with with
you
and the most uncomfortable time for me
was when everyone would feel
the holy ghost and start dancing around
and i would have no idea what to do and
i'm just standing there like
oh my god and everyone like i feel like
his mom would just look at me like side
eye like is she feeling the music
is she feeling the ghost is she really
into this i think your parents would
love me a lot more if i was christian
i think that um because of how religion
how religious your family is i think
they would
really want you to be with someone
that's actually
into god because um they comment on my
post all the time about
god this and got that and i don't ever
respond or delete or anything but
i feel like because i respect them they
should respect me also and not keep on
pushing that towards me and i feel like
some of them do it out of from
from a good intentions and some of them
do it from like
a bad place
oh god
[Music]
i forgot that argument that we always
have what is it when i ask you
are you you mean the one where it's like
well if god exists
why is there so much so much evil in the
world something like that i always
i always ask john like if there's a god
then why is there cancer why is there
this
that and then i get super emotional
about it you know why are there men
raping kids that believe they're
christian because then they do it and
then they say i'm a christian then it's
okay
but that's their excuse i feel like i do
take responsibility
by the way that i come off because it
comes off like
i'm not trying to hear anything like
yeah i hate these people why are they
doing this to these kids and
why are they doing this to the world i
feel like you don't know much about your
own religion
so when i ask you questions to be more
understanding you
like you i don't even think you want me
to believe in god
i think if you're a stronger christian i
think you would push it more upon me to
be honest because like i
when i want to know you don't really say
much all right here's the thing
i feel like simply because i do my best
to you know
be the not the i can say i'm not the
best christian but you know i do my best
to represent
christianity i'm just the type of person
to to know enough about the religion to
like make my own
decisions according to the religion
there's a lot of things that i feel like
you know
that's not in christ control that
happens
you know two people even the best people
in the world these are things that you
know
that are of the world and because we
live in this world you know
these are things that we have to deal
with as a whole that's why
it's a lot of questions that i say that
you know i can't answer simply because
like
it's not that i don't have the answer
it's just that i can only give you my
interpretation a lot of times like i
just
i just kind of just tune out you know
what other people have to say is
especially like when it comes to
religion because you know they're not
living pure lives themselves
so a lot of times all you can do is just
stay in your lane and just do
what it is that you need to do and not
focus on somebody else because i mean
let's be honest like i mean how many
people in the church you know get caught
doing crazy things
it's a lot of them so that's all they
say is they use it as an excuse
i mean they use it as a you know like as
a pacifier you know people use religion
as a pacifier
i remember i used to say all the time
that you are the only reason
the only reason in life that i would
even ever
possibly believe there's a god wow
because i wait
no stop no but um like i think everyone
that have you
in their life like as a son as a friend
as a neighbor
as you know like just a random person i
think everyone
anybody that meet you is just so lucky
because you're just like
to me i mean to everybody i think you're
like the best person in this
planet even though you joke a lot even
when i'm trying to be serious
i think you are you know
one of the reasons why i would believe
there's a god for sure
i really do appreciate you saying that
that's you know that's real as far as
my religion or you know my religion
change changing
i'm not atheist you know but i'm more
open to people other people having ideas
about things instead of just looking at
them being like
atheists for what you know i'm saying
like like because you are this person
you know i've learned to accept that
about you
and because i've learned to accept that
about you it kind of opens my
my perspective to a lot more people
would you like it more if i was
buddhist i like you just the way you are
do you i love you just the way you are
i definitely want to teach them because
like no matter what religion you're
you come from being a decent human being
that comes from all religion
there's so many rulings out there i
don't even know all of them you can be
whatever you know some people believe in
aliens
like that's the religious they can still
be a decent person and they believe in
aliens yeah of course
you can still be a good you can be a
christian and still be a bad person you
can still be
atheist and still be a good person a lot
of
students
do that black and be a good person have
to teach that with her parents
there's never a time where i want to say
like oh i'm going to make sure my kids
are
atheist like no because i want them to
be as free as possible
i want them to do whatever they please
and at the end of the day they have a
good heart and if it comes with good
intentions
then that's all that matters but i want
to add
also when i was going to the temples i
hated being there because
they're so close and believing in
buddha that they would judge everyone
around them and i definitely don't want
my kids to feel that way
there was a time i definitely thought
that i would raise my kids
i'm just strictly christian nothing else
it was a time like in my life where like
um you know things were just really
really really dark and then you know
somebody was like hey i got the answer i
mean here why don't you pick up that
bible over there
you know i'm not saying that you know i
use religion as an escape but i'm just
saying that it really really helped me
in that time of my life to take a
certain direction
and just as i became older and as i
became you know just more experienced
and
able to make my own decisions that's
when i was like well you know
it's easy to you know it's easy to kind
of like catch a dying fish
at that point i was like well i mean i'm
not saying you know my religion is a bad
thing like i love being christian but at
the same time i want my kids to make
their own decision
and not be you know and i don't want to
catch them at a vulnerable time just to
you know just to
place it upon them i want them to make
the educated decision for themselves
yeah for sure
[Music]
we actually value a lot like that are
the same i mean like you know we
we care for you know we care for the
world we care so much for other people
i think like we both care about family
it's very very important
i think our connection is really strong
because we're so different
but we accept it like our personalities
are so different
but we have a lot of like i think our
hearts are so similar
and i think that's what really really
matters
[Music]
you know just learn to find the you know
learn to seek the true beauty of people
and who they are you know in their heart
regardless of what they believe in
and if something that someone is really
really worth it
then i think that you should just accept
them no matter what
way shape or form they come in because
if you get into a relationship
you have to come you have to take to go
with the bad everything that comes with
it i definitely think that we should
focus on the good times that we've had
together no matter
what religion you're from i don't think
that's something that
ever really divided us it definitely
made us stronger it definitely made us
question our relationship but maybe
we're so different it's a good thing
like maybe we believed in god both of us
believe in god we wouldn't be so
understanding of each other
i just think that uh people pay way too
much way too much attention to
you know religion and things that we've
been trained to go through
since birth rather than to
make their own distinction of what they
truly believe so that they that way they
can accept
other people and the things that they
[Music]
believe
[Music]
you